[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
hält meine lieben freunde gefragt mich
wahrscheinlich schon hey lukas sein
letztes video doch in dem gebäude dort
beendet warum schießt jetzt hier vorne
das liegt ganz einfach daran weil ich
mich wohin einfach so ein bisschen hier
vorgestellt habe und diese ganzen öfen
hier mal dabei beobachtet habe wie sie
meine quad blöcke zu glatten quarz
blöcke verwandeln und da fällt mir auch
direkt auf das ich ja hier im inventar
sogar noch normale quarzwerke drin habe
also bibel hier rein diese kommen dann
hier unseren genen ofen kommen noch
diese hier rein und hier kommen auch
noch die rein da muss ich mir noch ganz
kurz ein bisschen kohle hohen ich habe
mir auf dem konto als du das ist richtig
ich hole mal ganz kurz ein bisschen
kohle und was ich hab's immer gepredigt
man kann immer kollege brauchen ich
würde sagen dass wir uns dann einfach
ein bisschen aktien stämme nehmen die
benötige ich ja ähnlich was ich
allerdings auch noch mitnehmen muss und
meine goldbarren und hier unten meine
gold spitzhacke die muss ich nämlich
republik du solltest mal deinen scheiß
hausdach was ich machen wollte meine
freunde war erstmal hier vorne akazien
stimme rein ich hoffe man dass 16 stück
erreichen hier vorne die kohle ist auch
schon fast leer aufwand der hier kann
ich erst mal noch ein bisschen kohle
reinhauen was sich in der zwischenzeit
allerdings machen möchte ist meine gold
spitzhacke zu reparieren denn wir haben
für heute wieder extra kostet wir haben
für heute auf jeden fall wieder extrem
viel auf unserer to do liste
ich glaube ich habe noch nie vor einer
folge so viel mit
ganz kurze time netz wie ich mich mal
eben kurz hier sortiere ich glaube ich
habe mein credo jeder steht auch in
fest- oder nicht dass er trinkt man
minecraft ist irgendwie hängengeblieben
glaube ich habe ich glaube hier mit dem
schwein passt auf jeden fall alles er
bleibt auf jeden fall hier stehen okay
du dich da schon der trinkt jetzt sie
irgendwie dass man das schweigen und das
kathi vorne mal auch ich glaube ich habe
irgendetwas kaputt gemacht gerade bin
nicht ganz ehrlich das schwein kommt auf
jeden fall vorne wieder raus die sache
ist allerdings dass ich irgendwie keine
kisten eröffnen kann also ich bin hier
vorne gerade zudem fassmer hingelaufen
und das problem ist halt dass ich dort
meine quarzwerke reinpacken
jetzt geht's also die ganzen quatsch
blöcke ich hier rein ihr seht auch schon
sieht man mich einmal geholt ich habe
meine trank der unter wasser atmen
geholt und ich werde jetzt um das wird
sich der ein oder andere wahrscheinlich
schon denken können mich zurück zum
ozean moment bewegen denn ich benötige
noch einige see laternen für unter
anderem dort da fehlt noch eine hier
hinten zur beleuchtung auf denen auch
noch welche da hab ich ja gerade noch
übergangsweise so ein bisschen fackeln
bei mir im erdgeschoss der villa ich
weiß man dass man hier sieht ja sieht
man hier vorne die beiden fackeln die
kommen auf jeden fall weckt scheiß bot
da hinten kommt auch noch mal weg wie
ich werde da nicht sterben ich habe mich
nach dem leck des wegen
wieder nicht sterben blödmann
wir werden uns auf jeden fall in
richtung ozean monument bewegen und
davor jedoch noch einmal kurz hier
schlafen gehen denn ich habe keine lust
dass wir dann dort unter wasser sind und
einerseits noch in welche zombies im
wasser spawnen auf der anderen seite wir
allerdings auch nicht sehen können denn
ich habe mir jetzt auch kein trank der
unterwasser sehr nachtsicht gemacht
heißt es ja sondern nur ein trank der
unterwasser atmung so dass ich unter
wasser vernünftig atmen kann
deswegen bin ich da ein bisschen auf
mich allein gestellt ich werde unter
wasser nicht so gut sehen können nicht
packt mir auch mal direkt hier gegen die
da schon gut los erinnert weiß mode
wieder angezogen von diesem was geht
denn hier ab
ich will einfach noch ein brot zurück
ich will nicht wir sind auf ob sie die
anhöhe es genau ist will einfach nur
hoch
ich hätte jetzt wieder runtergezogen
alter ich bin nicht mal ansatzweise bei
dem portal auch bei dem wir voll in der
spur
da muss ich hin ich würde sagen wir
lassen das brot jetzt auch wir fahren
noch ein bisschen hin
bin gespannt ich will eigentlich nicht
in den schwarm raum da wurde mir auch
ein kommentar geschrieben von wegen luca
der schwamm raum der es mega die sie zu
finden da will ich gar nicht hin das
einzige was ich machen möchte ist
wirklich diese see laternen abbauen die
ich für meine villa benötige ich habe
doch keinen effekt bekommen ich weiß
nicht wann ich team bekomme vielleicht
kriege ich noch gar nicht da muss ich
meine milch einmal nicht verschwenden
dich erstmal hier ganz kurz töten können
man kriegt den effekt erschreckt dass
ich mich noch total ich weiß nicht wie
das in meinem fach zu exorbitant laut
gemacht haben
warum stehe ich also ich hab den traktor
oder wasser haben nicht getrunken
stellen wir ein pfeifen und jetzt geht's
los das problem ist wenn ich jetzt den
effekt bekommen da kann ich nicht mehr
unter wasser atmen weil ich den jetzt
schon getrunken
und dann auch alltag
er hat mir auf ich habe hier schon
wieder komplett das kannst du doch nicht
aussehen ich will einfach nur lass mich
in ruhe ich will einfach nur kurz die
man ich gehe jetzt einfach kurz macht
ihr das so laut
euro was werde ich attackiert vier
herzen
warum hat hier nämlich etwa ein bisschen
dicker ich habe euch nichts getan
[Musik]
23 märz ich brauche noch zwei laternen
ich weiß nicht ob ich das hinkriege in
der zeit wo ich noch dämlich einmal so
keine effekte habe weil ja die ganze
zeit mehr effekte kommen
ich muss die allerdings abbauen ich
brauche die für meine strandvilla also
immer schnell hier hinten hin denn hier
schnell vergessen
ich verlass mich in rotem scheiß
arschloch
ich sehe mir die kommentare von wegen
lukas immer mehr milch alkohol tja ich
weiß ich bin dumm
versuch nummer zwei freunde ich habe mir
drei neue milch einmal gut das hat ja
gerade schon alles gesehen
den effekt habe ich auch noch nicht
bekommen ich brauche wie gesagt noch
zwei ventilatoren da ist der effekt wenn
man stellt die milch trinken hier einmal
kurz das ding kapoor ist jetzt auch egal
wäre nämlich angreifen greift mich ruhig
an mir doch nicht so ganz egal brach ich
kann ich auch wieder keine luft mehr
also halbe herzen du blödmann du regst
dich schon die ganze zeit regt mich auf
endlich weiter
grün ist alles scheiße ich war einfach
meine blöden verteilen lässt sich diese
blöden see laternen hoffentlich kriege
und dann zurück zu meiner insel fahrer
so freunde ich habe gerade 15 minuten
lang mit einem eps eingeblendet also für
euch waren es wahrscheinlich zehn
sekunden oder so weil ich das wieder auf
7.000 facher geschwindigkeit abgespielt
habe die sache ist allerdings dass ich
nicht nur mir diese laternen geholt habe
sondern mir außerdem eine menge brot
gemacht habe und mir drei betten gemacht
habe
und da fragt ihr euch jetzt
wahrscheinlich luca warum hast du denn
rabatten gemacht ja ich habe mir gedacht
ich habe heute keine zeit hier meine
inseln bis hin zu erweitern deswegen
stehe ich jetzt erstmal hier vorne hin
ihr habe ich ein bisschen schiss hin
dass die hier nicht ins wasser fallen
wir brauchen auf jeden fall die becken
denn ich möchte die village ein bisschen
formieren und dafür muss ich den ja
immer so ein bisschen brot hier
hinschmeißen also jeder von euch nimmt
sich mir mal bitte ein bisschen was dann
könnt ihr nämlich miteinander vermehren
und dann kann ich mir schlussendlich
hier ein lesepult hinstellen und einer
von denen wird dann hoffentlich endlich
meine bibliothek also hier beiden könnt
euch mal bitte auch noch ein bisschen
brötchen hier vorne sammelte die 1
die sammeln die eine perfekte hier vorne
nicht hört da habt ihr jeder 1 hier
werde ich habe keine ahnung hat er hier
vorne welche die sammeln die auf jeden
fall auf einen die beiden familien die
sich schon oder nicht ich weiß es nicht
genau
die haben auf jeden fall die liebe
zeichen deswegen muss ich ganz ganz ganz
ganz fix das lesepult nun holen und das
vor diesen neuen villagers setzen bzw
wird das ja erst ein baby glaube ich
also das sollte glaube ich kein problem
darstellen wo ist mein leben
[Musik]
people
ist aber auch egal freunde denn wir
können uns ganz fix einfach ein neues
lesepult kräften und dieses lesepult
dann einfach hier vorne würde ich sagen
auf die brücke setzen denn irgendwer von
denen wird hier ja schon daran
vorbeilaufen und wenn dieser kleine
villiger der hier vorne gerade so spaßig
herum hüpft dann irgendwann mal hier
über laufen sollte dann geht er auf
jeden fall hier vorne das lesepult oder
falsch ist dass er nach vorne zu den
block hin geht es auch egal dass du dir
auf jeden fall schon schaffen wir können
uns jetzt allerdings nun endlich mal ist
immer noch nicht alles fertig mein
schild darin packen
ich brauche ich ihn einfach es geht um
minecraft kohle nicht aufkommen ich
verbrenne auf jeden fall noch ein paar
zäune einfach und packt die hier vorne
rein dann warten wir noch kurz bis sie
an der beiden teile gefertigt sind denn
dann können wir uns zusammen endlich die
kompletten glatten quarzwerke nehmen und
uns heute jetzt endlich nach der ganzen
zeit die bereits vergangen ist um das
kümmern was im titel steht meine lieben
freunde denn ich möchte ihnen heute die
zweite etage meiner villa bauen
ich kann das husten verschrieben
ich habe schon oft in diesen strandvilla
bau folgen gesagt dass ich irgendwas
machen will was dann schlussendlich
nicht geschafft habe ich zu wenig quarz
hatte allerdings habe ich jetzt 10 6 und
das müssen wir glaube ich in kriegen
also schön tür schließen
die sonne werde ich wieder hier vorne
rein packen unsere holz in unserer
holzkiste und was ich mir auch mitnehmen
werde ist selbstverständlich ein gerüst
das wollen können auf jeden fall
gebrauchen den rest hier den habe ich
auf jeden fall auch im staat muss sollte
alles passen und laufen noch mal in dem
schiffchen vorbei
tun wir das schaf nämlich habe ich in
finnland jetzt habe ich auch die ganze
zeit mit rechts drauf gemacht ich hab
schon 20 braune wolle wir brauchen
glaube ich insgesamt 30 oder 40 für den
kopf das heißt eventuell schon in der
nächsten sommer über nächsten folge
können doch endlich das tribut für den
für die verstorbene neben das schaf
setzen allerdings kümmern wir uns jetzt
erst mal um die wieder hier vorne
eur vj
denn davon weg helfen muss einfach nur
entspannt nach hochspringen dann kommst
du noch weg oder wo ist der genau denn
du willst du doch einfach du steckst
deinen kopf in den sand
das kriegt jetzt hin wenn die lieben
freunde von daher sage ich euch erst mal
ganz gut was ich vorhabe
es ist geisteskrank wie viele glatte
quarzwerke ich hier habe die sache ist
allerdings dass wir uns erst mal um das
hier vorne kümmern also da werde ich
jetzt nämlich hier eine see laterne
reinsetzen darunter die eisen falschen
da sehen wir schon haben wir deutlich
kleinere ist einspannte rissen licht
also nicht unbedingt entspannter aber
auf jeden fall kleineres licht hier wird
immer noch in sandstein ich habe hier
auch immer noch netter quarz daher den
sandstein kann ich auf jeden fall
nachher mal holen was ich ihnen erst mal
alles nicht brauche packe ich mal hier
vorne hinstellen ich benötige jetzt
erstmal eine menge klasse quartz blöcke
da habe ich ja hier ist es wirklich
unfassbar wie viel ich davon habe als
ich hoffe mal dass wir heute wirklich
mit der zweite etage fertig werden
sollten
denn zuallererst dafür meine lieben
freunde haben wir allerdings das gerüst
von daher kümmern wir uns als
allererstes erstmal um einen kleinen
fehler die ich gebaut habe denn hier
[Musik]
das ganze glas muss weg ich habe voll
vergessen dass hier mein schlafzimmer
hinkommt aber ich würde sagen dass wir
das glas erstmal auch hier lassen bis es
dann so weit ist denn die nächste sache
die wir falsch bord haben war also
irgendwie besteht diese ganze villa
jauss falsch worten ich glaube es gibt
keinen einzigen block dem ich hinterher
springen würde ausland glatten quartz
blog wir müssen nun auf jeden fall
erstmal hier vorne alles zugleich dann
mit quartz so dass das ganze
schlussendlich so aussieht und dann
müssen wir hier vorne an der treppe
lange wand rum ziehen also so muss das
laufen und hier vorne muss die dann auch
weitergehen allerdings hier vorne sogar
zwei blog breit da müsst ihr nämlich
erst mal das hier vorne rüberziehen
genau bis hier vorne hin und dann hier
die wand rüber und diese jedem 2 block
breit dann müssen wir hier vorne 123456
rübergehen nicht hier den block dann
abbauen dort konnten
nämlich eine laterne hole ich gleich und
dann hier wieder 1 2 3 4 5 und wieder
hier vorne auch eine see laterne hin
dafür habe ich die beiden nämlich geholt
die wand von hier vorne ziehen wir jetzt
hier vorne so rüber und setzen nun auch
hier auf die laterne einen quartz lock
und ziehen die wand bis hier vorne hin
und setzen nun auch hier vorne über
unsere see laternen die man ja nur dann
von unten sieht auch quartz blöcke und
nun sehen wir von hier vorne eins zwei
drei vier fünf blöcke und ziehen dann
hier vorne auch noch mal eine quante
rüber die sache ist dass ich jetzt hier
vorne ja auch quatsch blöcke hingesetzt
habe das soll allerdings nicht sagen das
habe ich nur gerade gesetzt damit ich
genau weiß bis wohl nicht dass hier
ziehen muss denn hier vorne kommen
schwarze glasscheiben hin und hier vorne
auch das wird so ein bisschen das
geländer beziehungsweise die wand wieder
verschoben hatte ich dachte fed steht
denn jetzt hier in meiner welt die sache
ist allerdings dass ich das gleich
machen werde denn die sonne geht schon
wieder runter und ich habe hier vorne
noch eben einen quartz blog zu holen
die sache ist jetzt auch dass ich mal
eben schnell ein gerüst hin mitnehmen
werde und ich muss mir eigentlich auch
noch auf jeden fall eine spitzhacke
machen mit behutsamkeit die allerdings
aus eisen ist das nicht für da vorne ein
bisschen was habe
ich brauche immer noch ein namensschild
und das ich wollte sagen ich kann mir
das ding nicht kräften weil ich das
finden muss das weiß ich selbst nicht so
genau
kurzschlaf werde liebe freude und dann
haben wir auch schon wieder einen neuen
tag und müssen uns nun wirklich darum
kümmern dass wir gut wenn sie klein
zombies frau sind viel aggressiver als
die großen finde ich also ich gebe mal
ganz kurz beide eben das verrottete
fleisch hier vorne und neben mir jetzt
hier vorne eine eisen spitzhacke raus
habe ich noch eine neue effizienz 1
haltbarkeit brauche halt auf jeden fall
behutsamkeit von daher mache ich mir
einfach ganz kurze neue zack zack 2
davon und drei eisen 123 die beiden
packe ich jetzt so hier rein und so hier
rein und jetzt können wir mal ganz gut
und habe ich hier noch ein buffet der
fall haltbarkeit drei sälen läufer und
feder fall
ich kann es noch mal versuchen mit einem
buch hier in die verzauberung
reinzugehen
die sache ist dass das halt alles die
gründe sind warum ich eigentlich
wirklich einen bibliothekar brauche also
irgendein villa der mit dem lesepult
einen beruf ergattert und da ist halt
das problem dass sich halt erst mal
warten muss bis sich der typ da vorne
ins ausgewachsenen ausgewachsenen
zustand bewegt also ich bekomme
effizienz nur effizienz mehr nicht was
würde ich unten bekommen glück zwei das
allerdings auch nichts wenn ich ein buch
rein packe bekomme ich schutz und schutz
sicher ich brauche halt einfach da man
das ist wir können es halt auf gut glück
probieren dass ich es einfach rein packe
dann kriege ich vielleicht effizienz und
noch was allerdings nicht nur effizienz
und jetzt hab ich neue erfahrung sehr
viel verballert
also ist aber auch egal da müssen wir
wohl auf unsere gold spitzhacke
zurückgreifen die habe ich allerdings
gerade auch nicht dabei von daher muss
ich die ganz kurz holen und hoffen dass
sich damit genügend von den glasplatten
abbauen kann
sonst ist es allerdings auch nicht
weiter schlimm da nehme ich einfach
schwarzen farbstoff und gelassen habe
ich sogar noch ich habe sogar noch genug
glas dann mach ich das habe ich einfach
so dann verständig jetzt nicht meine
spitzhacke ich auch noch ihr genug glas
also packen wir das jetzt einfach hier
vorne so rein ich glaube ich kann
einfach so machen sagt das hier drum rum
dann bekomme ich diese glasglocke und
wenn ich dann diese glasbrücke so
anordnen bekomme ich auf jeden fall
genügend schwarze glasscheiben also das
sollte definitiv reichen da müssen wir
wirklich jetzt nicht den weg gehen mit
der komischen behutsamkeit spitzhacke
die wir uns allerdings eben ezer machen
müssen
das ist alles noch nicht fertig wir
wurden auch wieder so extrem viele
weitere sachen in die kommentare
geschrieben die ich umsetzen kann in
diesem projekt allerdings muss sich
wirklich erst mal gucken dass ich meine
bestehenden punkte auf dieser liste
abarbeiten kann der unterwasser tunnel
ist überhaupt noch nicht fertig der
sollte eigentlich komplett eingegipst
werden
die muss ich generell immer schöner
machen wir haben auch fast noch gar
nicht genutzt weil ich eigentlich nie da
hinten auf dem fest bald bin ich dachte
dass ich da deutlich häufiger am start
bin allerdings konzentrieren wir uns
jetzt erstmal auf die strandvilla
freunde und dementsprechend auch auf das
geländer
was nämlich hier vorne hin kommen soll
sagt sagt das werden wir natürlich
nachher auch noch voll hochziehen
da ist das ding das ich spätestens dann
auf jeden fall noch mehr glasscheiben
brauche allerdings jetzt erst mal ganz
kurz zum andeuten reicht das definitiv
hier vorne nämlich auch und dann sieht
schon mal so aus es wird später wirklich
ziemlich geil aussehen nun müssen wir
allerdings die kompletten wende 1 234
hoch setzen also insgesamt wirklich fünf
blöcke hoch und ich glaube dass sich
jetzt entscheiden wird ob wir das
hinkriegen mit dem ganzen kreis oder ob
wir wirklich noch mal in die hölle gehen
müssen
[Musik]
walter alt so komme ich leider nicht
also ich habe die wände hochgezogen
allerdings muss hier halt noch in dachau
weiß ich brauche hier für locker noch 26
und hierfür auch noch so ein steak also
drei starts müssten es auf jeden fall
noch sein
die sache ist allerdings jetzt quasi
schon rübergezogen habe ich habe das
glas hier vorne noch nicht abgebaut
hier muss eigentlich auch noch quad sind
allerdings gucken wir dann nachher
neuwahlen park blöcke muss ich auch noch
entfernen weil dort dann auch noch glas
blöcke von außen ran kommen also zum
beispiel hier an der seite hier vorne
kommt noch eine riesige glaswand hin
weil ich mir dann gedacht habe dass man
da vorne den sonnenuntergang an schönen
sehen kann
die sonne geht auch schon wieder unter
deswegen muss ich mich auch ganz ganz
fix hier widerspiegeln
ich nehme jetzt mal alle sachen die ich
im inventar habe mit hier vorne habe ich
noch diese laterne die benötige ich
eigentlich nicht mehr die bloß da war
ich auch nicht mehr nehme ich auch mal
ganz kurz eben mit und dann schauen wir
uns das ganze jetzt mal von der vorne an
die sache ist nämlich dass man glaube
ich schon erkennen kann wie es dann
schlussendlich final aussehen wird denn
meine lieben freunde ein wenig konnte
ich heute doch fertig stellen von der
standort und jetzt gerade sieht sie so
aus
ja irgendwie sieht sie nicht so nah ist
schau mal eben von hier ganz normal die
wolle weg von unserem cook baum hier
oben da hinten los blue cross und hier
vorne
ich habe vergessen da auszuleuchten ist
aber auch egal freunde denn ich werde
jetzt mal ganz fix eben schnell
schlafengehen ich hoffe dass ich hier
keinem einzigen monster begegne sodass
niemand irgendwie die luft fliegt oder
hinten so weit kommt oder so sieht
allerdings relativ gut aus also mal ganz
fix eben schlafen gehen und dann wollte
ich in der heutigen episode auch noch
mal ganz schnell gucken ob wir das mit
dem villiger hinkriegen so dass der den
bibliotheks beruf annehmen kann also da
schauen wir auch noch mal ganz schnell
nach denn das wäre wirklich wundervoll
wenn wir dann irgendwelche sachen
vernünftig verzögern könnten
ich glaube allerdings dass das bisher
nicht geklappt hat ist der wille da
überhaupt schon erwachsen geworden ja
ist ja wir haben hier in fischermeister
frischer experten waffenschmied
neulingen die beiden haben sogar hier
erneut irgendwelche sachen am start wie
die gerade veranstalten von daher nehme
ich jetzt erstmal ganz kurz mein
lesepult ihm mit und bau jetzt auch hier
vorne die blöcke ab die eventuell dafür
gesorgt haben dass einer von denen diese
berufe angenommen hat also diese beiden
brauche ich jetzt auch mal schauen wer
von denen jetzt hier keinen beruf mehr
glaube jeder oder oder habe ich
irgendwelche anderen blöcken er hat
keinen beruf mehr das heißt jetzt jedoch
irgendwohin oder bedingt ein okay wir
haben die videotheken und er hat
rückstoß ich muss trotz mit dem traden
damit er den beruf behält also noch
einmal ganz fix eben schnell smaragde
holen so dass ich das lesepult abbauen
kann denn es ist so dass wenn jemand neu
ein beruf annimmt und man dann seinen
arbeits blog abbaut also in seinem falle
dann halt was wollte er wollte nämlich
branche hat
ich rede jetzt einfach nur mit ihm damit
ich mit ihm geredet habe die sache ist
wenn ich dann einmal mit ihm geredet
habe dann kann ich ruhig sein
arbeitsplatz abbauen und er behält
seinen beruf haben sogar noch einen
neuen kleinen villagers vielleicht wird
er dann auch ein lesepult mensch
deswegen könne nicht mehr jetzt hier
erstmal die bücherregal ich muss ihm
halt irgendwie hochleveln auf ein neues
level muss ich mir noch ein paar mehr
smartphone ich brauche eigentlich gar
nicht die ganze bücherregale aber ich
muss ihnen halt ein bisschen hoch
kriegen damit ich irgendwann eventuelle
reparatur bekomme das wäre extrem geil
und halt einfach behutsamkeit das wird
mich auch sehr freuen
allerdings meine lieben freunde die
folge hat mal wieder ein bisschen
überlänge wegen der ganzen times ist mit
dem ozean moment und ich am bauen und so
weiter und so fort
bin ich wieder bei anderthalb stunden
deswegen will ich das heute wieder der
stellt jetzt auch beenden freuen wenn es
euch gefallen hat dann das geld einen
daumen hoch und ein video hier da
abonniert neuen kanal und klickt auf die
glocke wenn ihr neue videos nicht
verpassen wollte ich habe keine ahnung
warum ich jetzt gerade so ein stress ist
so der hier verwandelt sich jetzt auf
jeden fall das war noch mal ganz kurz
eben ab ich will nämlich sehen was seine
neuen angebote dann sind und was er dann
unsere sachen am start immer noch
rückstoß wie kriege ich smaragde und ich
kriege laternen das bringt mir alles
nichts
ich konnte ein paar laternen noch eben
können
ich muss dann halt einfach nur
hochleveln dafür verschwende ich glaube
meine ganzen smaragde das ist total
unnötig also laternen holen sagt er
bleibt jetzt wieder und dann haben wir
ihnen jetzt gleich auch schon auf der
nächsten stufe oder als geselle
wir haben rückstoß und verbrennung warum
kriegen was mache ich falsch freunde
ich will einfach nur reparatur und
behutsamkeit vielleicht schaffen wir es
in der nächsten folge schreibt mir gerne
in die kommentare was ich dann machen
sollen wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder
[Musik]